lululemon comes under fire for lack of
diversity despite its woke virtue
signaling
trump sues big tech and joe biden hands
afghanistan over to the taliban i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show ben
shapiro show is sponsored by expressvpn
why haven't you gotten a vpn yet visit
expressvpn.com
slash ben we'll get to all the news in
just one moment first a reminder another
thousand
of you my extremely wise listeners
you've already made the switch from your
overpriced wireless
carrier to pure talk over the past
couple of months because you wanted to
save money so what are the rest of you
waiting for
if you have cell phone coverage with one
of the big providers you are spending
too much money it is that simple if
you're with atc
or verizon or t-mobile your family could
save over 800
a year just by switching to pure talk
you get the same great coverage because
they use the exact same towers as one of
the big carriers you can even keep your
phone and your number but you will save
a fortune in the process by the way
pure talk is the top rated wireless
company by consumer affairs with the
absolute best customer service team
based right here in america
if that sounds good it gets even better
right now get a limited talk text and
six gigs of data for just 30 bucks a
month
and if you go over on the data they're
not going to charge you for it grab your
mobile phone
dial pound 250 say ben shapiro when you
do you'll save 50
off your very first month now pound 250
say
keyword ben shapiro pure talk is simply
smarter wireless and you're not being
smart if you don't switch over to peer
talk today
go check them out right now dial pound
250 say ben shapiro to get started and
get 50
off your very first month of coverage
alrighty so
the bosses at lululemon they must have
thought that they were gonna be okay
they must have thought that everything
was gonna be fine after all they've
spent the last
several years virtue signaling on a wide
variety of issues
you may recall that just last year
lululemon came under fire
after they tweeted out that it was time
to decolonize gender
and it was time to resist capitalism you
remember it was
an event that was featured in an
instagram post in which lululemon
recommended
other accounts to follow including the
host of the workshop a person named reby
kern
yogan's that yoga instructor is a
us-based brand ambassador
for the firm now a lot of people at the
time pointed out lululemon sells like
pairs of yoga pants by the way quick
side swipe of yoga pants not actual
clothing
in any case lululemon sells these very
overpriced yoga pants to
middle income to upper income women with
dispensable
capital and they were ripping on
capitalism and that's not where the
virtue signaling the woke virtue
signaling
ended of course you'll remember that
lululemon was a big pusher in the black
lives matter movement
they started putting out the black
square and they started telling
everybody at their company they had to
sort of mirror the
corporate message well now now the woke
come for the ask not for whom they will
come they come for thee lululemon and
thy yoga pants
according to business insider in spring
2020 days after the murder of george
floyd a high level lululemon manager
told a team of designers and copywriters
she wanted to put all lives matter at
the top
of lululemon's website amid black lives
matter demonstrations across north
america lululemon had been scrambling in
its vancouver british columbia
headquarters to craft a response to the
events
suddenly dominating the news cycle over
the course of the afternoon on june 1st
the company put together a task force to
develop copy and graphics to present to
top brass
and quickly publish to its website the
team of about 10 employees had spent
hours mocking up a version of the home
page featuring black lives matter as the
headline because you'll remember it is
very
important in the modern age that every
major corporation mirror whatever is the
woke priority of the day
i know most of you you really didn't
care whether a yoga pants company was
signaling about black lives mattering
particularly a yoga pants company
that largely caters to upper class white
ladies but
it was very important to lululemon that
they do this it was very important that
they signal to
everyone how much that company that
makes
overpriced extremely tight fitting
bottoms how they
signal about systemic american police
racism supposedly
they were interrupted by a manager
however according to for former current
employee and current employees close to
the matter it is so amazing how the
inside outside game
now works at these corporations it
really is incredible all you have to
have
is a couple of employees who go and leak
to the media and then the media
suggests that your company is racist or
sexist or bigoted in some way
and then you're not allowed to fire
those people because of course these are
good-hearted whistleblowers you're not
allowed to look for the folks who are
just trying to destroy your company from
the outside and run your company
based on this inside outside game all
you have to do is craft a media response
from the inside these leakers and
suddenly the entire corporate structure
is going to be responding to 21 year old
interns that's how all of this works
so that's the story lululemon a bunch of
people leaked
to business insider they said the
manager a director who they added had
not been previously involved in the
project demanded that the group use new
approved copy
near the beginning of the proposed text
the phrase all lives matter appeared in
capital letters
we are not writing black lives matter
that's not where we're at the director
told the group according to two
employees present in the room
after significant debate the employees
several of whom are black indigenous and
people of color
agreed to create two designs to present
to leadership one with all lives matter
another with black lives matter
while black lives matter was ultimately
selected an employee who was involved in
the homepage project said they felt
triggered and traumatized and described
it as one of the most disgusting moments
in their time at lululemon my god the
yoga pants company a person
about their final policy mirrored the
policy priorities
of these people of color who are
low-level staffers inside the company
finally the company agreed with the
low-level staffers who are people of
color
we're now leaking to the media but the
fact that somebody even pushed back
it was just devastating you cannot have
pushback in the corporate world
all must be ousted all must be destroyed
after all of these black employees all
these people of color said we cannot go
forward with this
and please don't make us have to mock
this up for you and her saying we have
to do it it was a very
traumatic experience it's unbelievable
they had to write the words all lives
matter
in a mock-up that they didn't use oh the
heart flutters
at the level of threat faced by these
employees at a yoga pants company
lululemon then ended up putting out
word an instagram post that said words
have power actions have more power
many corporations stumbled in their
internal and external communication
after the murder of george floyd but
even before spring 2020
all lives matter had been widely
recognized as a phrase that downplayed
the black lives matter movement
the director was given the chance to
apologize to a group of about 200
copywriters designers and photographers
on a conference call ah the obligatory
internal now struggle session
we have to make sure that this director
knew he
had sinned and he will atone
many of these copywriters designers and
photographers were unaware of the events
for which the director was apologizing
which of course
is part and parcel of all this it's not
directed just at the director
of course it is directed at all of the
low-level employees who will shut up or
face the same treatment
the director left lululemon shortly
after the apology so he made the apology
and then he left
so you didn't get the benefit of the
apology then from the outside lululemon
exudes an aspirational lifestyle with
its high-tech active war and brightly
curated 500-plus retail stores designed
to reflect the company's core values of
personal responsibility entrepreneurship
honesty courage connection fun and
inclusion according to its website
lululemon has a 4.4 billion dollars
in sales every year it has only
accelerated its growth chair under ceo
calvin mcdonald thanks to his strategic
investments
in growing categories like menswear
e-commerce and connected fitness
including the acquisition of mirror in
june 2020
but according to 12 current and former
lululemon corporate employees who spoke
with insider the company's image stands
in stark contrast
to their experiences behind the scenes
at the company's corporate
offices my god i can't wait to tell you
about the sorts of oppression
happening at the yoga pants company
we'll get some more of this in just one
second because it is indicative of how
companies are now being run
and it is indicative of the
authoritarian moment that we are
currently
experiencing and that is stretching out
across the corporate landscape
and in some cases being facilitated by
government we'll get to that in just one
second first
let's talk about clothing that fits you
exactly right
i'm talking of course about cuts
clothing fellas the sport of business
means demanding excellent from your
craft and your wardrobe your fits it
needs to be versatile blending timeless
style and comfort so you look as good as
you feel for that there is cuts
clothing let me just tell you every
t-shirt i own is now cuts clothing
t-shirts i mean
they are that good they've taken a
classic men's fashion staple the plainty
they've refined it they combine premium
quality with minimalist aesthetic
cuts shirts pillows hoodies crew
sweatshirts they're made for the man who
works hard plays hard never settles for
less all
in the sport of business in 2016 cuts
founder steve borelli set out to create
clothes ready for every occasion the
modern man faces
and he started by reinventing that
t-shirt the end result what gq magazine
calls the only shirt
worth wearing it is indeed a buttery
soft because they have pika pro
it's a try blended tee it's a bold new
take on a classic design it combines the
ultimate blend
of high quality cotton polyester and
spandex as well it is the perfect
t-shirt and now
cuts set out to create uniquely
engineered fabric
called hyperloop french carry fabric for
their hoodies it's a textile that is
temperature controlled
and ageless you don't need to take it
off and you won't want to it's just
great stuff all they do is make
excellent clothes they've got the pica
polo
it's a design that keeps you fitted for
the office or the golf course or at home
it's not just a lifestyle it's not just
clothing it is office leisure apparel
for the sport of business get 15
off your first order by going to
cutsclothing.com shapiro that is
cutsclothing.com
shapiro for 15 off the only shirt worth
wearing alrighty back to
lululemon so again the way that this
works is you get a couple of your fellow
employees to go and talk to business
insider and then you pressure
a company that does 4.4 billion dollars
in sales every year
to mirror your corporate work priorities
some corporate employees
said they felt that the rapid growth of
the company had hindered its ability to
implement changes
particularly in areas like diversity and
inclusion that have long plagued
lululemon the employees who spoke with
insider did so on condition of anonymity
for fear of jeopardizing their current
and future employment opportunities by
the way
you should fear jeopardizing your
current and future business
opportunities when you
talk out of school about a company that
is paying you just a general rule
when the company is not violating the
law when you just don't like the
priorities of the company
if you talk out of school about that
they have every right to fire you
there's nothing in employment law that
suggests that when you and moan
about their diversity policies this
means they must listen to you
it is it is an absurdity of the highest
order that
these corporate heads don't just run
their companies how they should normally
run their companies
again i'm the head of my company you
know what happened if one of my
producers started talking out of school
about the company all the problems we
have in turn we have lots of procedures
we have an hr department for any
problems inside the company you start
going outside the company and talking
to members of the media about how
terrible the company you work for is the
boss has every right
and they an obligation to fire your ass
and put you on the unemployment line
in any case business insider the
suggestion is that lululemon is deeply
racist because they
they acquiesced to the left wing they
were woken up for the left wing for a
brief period of time
but you can never be woke enough that is
the dirty secret
according to business insider according
to one of the copywriters presents in
the room
several employees reported the director
who demanded the all lives matter
homepage design
so they reported him after the
director's tearful apology a copywriter
who had left the company the year prior
said she was notified of the incident by
her former colleagues and felt compelled
to send an email urging members of
management to fire the director okay so
you have somebody a copywriter who no
longer even worked at the company
emailing the heads of the company to
urge the firing of a person
she had no relations with and was not
even involved in the procedures with
you you're the bad guy here you're the
bad guy
copywriter who no longer works at the
company trying to get somebody to lose
their job for the great sin of proposing
an all lives matter post as opposed to a
black lives matter post
you're the bad guy you're a jerk and an
authoritarian a boot
the email was sent on june 8 2020 with
the subject line racism
privilege and inaction at lou lemon it
was addressed to the head of the company
mcdonald's chief brand officer nikki
neuberger susan golinas the senior vice
president of people and culture janelle
acker a former vice president of global
diversity and inclusion
and the lululemon board of directors it
is my ask of you
on behalf of many others who have
complained and who do not feel able to
speak on this issue publicly out of fear
for their employment that you remove
this person from your company
immediately she wrote in the email which
has been reviewed by
insider the former employee told insider
she didn't receive a response
but said the director left lululemon
shortly after her email was sent
stacia jones a vice president and head
of inclusion diversity equity and action
at lululemon which is a
filler of jobs as a matter of company
policy we do not comment on individual
employee situations
if anyone at lululemon has a negative
experience we have several ways for
employees to share their concerns and
feedback
we take feedback very seriously but
there was another
incident involving racial insensitivity
just weeks prior
at the height of the global coronavirus
outbreak in april 2020 when arts
director trevor fleming posted a link to
a t-shirt on his personal instagram
account the t-shirt had the title of
bat fried rice with a picture of a
chinese takeout box with batwings on the
front and the words no thank you on the
back and right sleeve
as in like don't eat the bats because it
started the global coronavirus pandemic
according to early reports before it
turned out it was actually probably just
a
chinese governmental lab leak in an
email to insider fleming said sharing
the t-shirt which was designed by an
acquaintance of his was a momentary
lapse of judgment and an incident he had
quote
spent the past year regretting i fully
understand the insensitivity associated
with the design he made
and deeply regret the pain i caused the
scandal followed an even earlier
incident man these are brutal incidents
it used to be that companies
in the united states actively
discriminated against members of racial
minorities
now a director posts a mildly
insensitive instagram
and suddenly all hell breaks loose that
scandal a scandal ooh
of epic proportions followed an earlier
incident in lululemon's history when
founder
and then ceo chip wilson wrote in a
since deleted post that the company's
name was chosen
as a marketing ploy to attract japanese
customers
a japanese marketing firm would not try
to create a north american sounding
brand with the letter l because the
sound does not exist in japanese
phonetics wilson wrote on the company's
blog by including an l in the name it
was thought the japanese consumer would
find the name innately north american
and authentic it's funny to watch them
try and say it he added
okay well it's a dumb comment a dumb
comment does not mean the entire company
is of course deeply racist
but everything has to be taken as though
it is a massive issue
and of course we'll have the obligatory
struggle sessions there'll be donations
to various interest groups ibrahim
kennedy will get a million-dollar
donation from lululemon probably
in order to ensure that they are
anti-racist enough they will buy they'll
participate in the system
of woke indulgences and none of this
will buy them anything
except for a notion that the next time
any employee has a problem they
immediately run back to business insider
and this is the entire goal now with
regard to corporate america you too can
pressure your bosses into doing the
bidding of the left
all you have to do is find some member
of the journactivist media
to cover it and you are good to go
because this is what journalism has
become the story here isn't about a
bunch of vocal employees who can't keep
their mouths shut
and violate their confidentiality
agreements it is not about that
the story is truly about a media that is
designed and created in order to be an
activist wing of the democratic party
there is no difference at this point
between business insider
or daily beast and media matters they
are all part of the same ecosystem their
entire design
is to pressure institutions that they
believe they can pressure into doing the
bidding of the left that is what all
these stories are about they're about
can you get an institution
to do what you want it's not about
covering something that is innately news
worthy what the hell is newsworthy about
a thing that happened
in 2020 that is not even mildly worthy
of of news coverage that a director said
all lives matter in 2020.
by the way this was the featured story
at twitter yesterday and this is not
just
me bringing up a story that is random on
the internet this was the featured story
all day on twitter.com and they'd
actually put it in their news feed on
the right side of the page
and because again all of the
journalistic entities that you know and
love are activist entities now some of
us
in the conservative side of the i will
say we're conservative we cover the news
from a particular
angle but the thing is that the media
ecosystem that proclaims that it is in
fact a sort of
objective news ecosystem is not it is
designed in the same way as media
matters
they run stories specifically in order
to pressure these corporations they run
the story specifically
in order to begin boycotts why do you
think it is that every time
a controversial comment is made you get
somebody from the huffington post
calling up advertisers of tucker
carlson's program and saying do you know
you advertise with tucker carlson
that question is not designed to elicit
a response that question is designed to
elicit an action
namely the advertiser getting scared and
cancelling tucker carlson
right that is what this is designed to
do the business insider story is
designed
in order to get lululemon to do whatever
the left wants it to do because this is
not innately newsworthy stuff
it's not the president of haiti being
assassinated in his home
it is not the united states pull out
from afghanistan it is a couple of woke
employees from lululemon who are
frustrated with their day jobs and bored
in their
in their new york apartments
but this is how this how the game works
right now and it has predictable impacts
in terms of politics because it turns
out that typically
when corporations are involved in
politics it's because for example they
want to
get people elected who are friendlier to
their business positions
but now the polarity has been reversed
politicians particularly on the
democratic side of the aisle are able to
activate
members of the media to now make the
corporations do what the politicians
want them to do
it used to be the notion that
corporations supported politicians
because
they wanted to get politicians elected
who would be beneficial to their agenda
now it is actually precisely the
opposite it's politicians who are
cuddling
businesses into doing what they want
them to do in the social sphere it's
fascinating
and they're doing so with the help of a
of a not compliant
a complicit media an activist media that
is deeply involved in every aspect of
this
we'll get to more of this in just one
second because this is becoming very
clear with regard to for example toyota
first let us talk about how you hire and
fire
so if you're a business owner who's
hiring you probably face a lot of
challenges when it comes to finding the
right person for your role
that's why hiring can feel like trying
to find a needle in a haystack sure you
could post your job to some job board
and all you can do is hope the right
person comes along that's why you should
try zip recruiter for free at
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire when you post a job on zip
recruiter it gets sent out to over 100
top job sites with just one click
then ziprecruiter's matching technology
finds the right people
with the right skills and experience for
your job and actively invites them to
apply in fact zip recruiter is so
effective
that four out of five employers who post
unzipper career get a quality candidate
within
the very first day it's no wonder over
2.3 million businesses have come to zip
recruiter for
their hiring needs so for example here
at daily wire
if you need a great producer like
elliott you know somebody who will make
sure that things
run on time but also give you terrible
recommendations about marvel movies that
you must must must watch
well then you need zip recruiter as well
while other companies overwhelm you with
way too many options zip recruiter finds
you what you're looking for the needle
in the haystack right now
you can try zip recruiter for free at
this web address zippercrew.com
dailywire once again remember go to this
unique place ziprecruits.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-ire zip recruiter is indeed
the smartest
way to hire all right so it's not just
lululemon of course this entire
sort of debacle is designed in order to
push corporations to do what the left
wants them to do the latest element of
this of course
is toyota has now announced it will stop
any donation to any republican member of
congress who voted against certifying
the 2020 presidential election
now presumably toyota is not going to do
this for for example jamie raskin
from maryland who you'll remember last
time around in 2016 voted against
certifying the election but according to
citizens for responsibility and ethics
in washington the company's pac
has given 56 000 to 38 members of
congress who objected to the
certification of the election on january
6th
and it is a very short step from this
particular thing listen i don't think
that anyone should have voted against
the certification of the election i
don't think there was a legal basis to
do so
i've been very very clear about this
with that said i don't think that
corporations
should be forced to to boycott
politicians
who agree with their particular business
agenda because
those politicians also supported a thing
with which
the company was not involved so for
example i do not think that companies
should be forced to stop giving money if
they if they are
into giving money to democrats based on
their economic agenda for some reason
i don't think that there should be a lot
of social pressure to force those
companies to stop giving money to
democrats based on the fact
that democrats support broadly speaking
crackdowns on religious freedom right if
it's a company that's not involved with
any of that sort of stuff i don't really
think those two things are related
but we have now come to the point where
anything that becomes a leftist talking
point is an excuse
to push corporations to not give to
republicans overall
that is the goal january 6th is just the
excuse and if it weren't january 6th it
would be something else it would be
anybody who supported donald trump
cannot be supported
by any sort of corporation because if
they do then they are supporting all of
the evils and excesses of donald trump
in a statement issued on thursday
japan-based automaker said it had quote
decided to stop contributing to those
members of congress who contested the
certification
toyota is committed to supporting and
promoting actions that further our
democracy said toyota
this is the same thing that stacey
abrams finally accomplished in georgia
when he saw corporations divesting from
the state of georgia because georgia
passed
a law voting shoring up voter id for
example and then
she realized oh this was a bad idea and
tried to back off of that toyota says
our company has long-standing
relationships with members of congress
across the political spectrum
especially those representing our u.s
operations our bipartisan pac equally
supports democrats and republicans
running for congress in fact
in 2021 the vast majority of
contributions went to democrats and
republicans who supported the
certification of the 2020 election
we understand that the pac decision to
support select members of congress who
contested the results
troubled some stakeholders we are
actively listening to our stakeholders
and at this time we've decided to stop
contributing to these members of
congress who contested the certification
of certain states in the 2020 election
the reason i pause on the word
stakeholders is because this is deeply
indicative
of a perverse view of how business is
supposed to work and there are two views
of how business is supposed to work one
is what is called shareholder capitalism
pushed by people like milton friedman
and the basic idea here is that a
company's main duty is to its
shareholders you buy stock in a company
and now the company has a duty to you
the company has a duty to
create a program that will allow for
long-term earnings the company has a
duty
to ensure that your stock price over
time does not go down that they make
good business decisions
and that's what shareholder capitalism
is all about that the people who
actually own a share of the company
are the people to whom the company's
board is responsible stakeholder
capitalism is a very different thing
stakeholder capitalism is a term that's
been coined by
quote-unquote intellectual elites to
suggest a system
in which corporations are answerable not
just to their own shareholders but to
the public at large
which really means to government actors
and the media stakeholders are people
who do not own chairs in the company who
don't own any they don't buy toyota cars
they don't have a share of toyota stock
they're just anyone who's affected by
toyota meaning
a person in the world and so if any
person in the world has a complaint
about toyota toyota will now respond to
those people
which of course means they are not
responding to economic concerns they are
not
focusing in on what makes their product
better and less expensive for the
consumer instead they are focused in
on pleasing particular political actors
who are the loudest stakeholder
capitalism again
is just a way of saying that your
corporate overlords ought to be
responding not to market incentives but
to non-market incentives they are not
responding
to the demands of the market they are
responding instead to the loudest
political actors out there
which is a form of corporatism in which
corporations act hand in glove with the
government and with the democrat media
complex
in order to cram down institutional
power
my new book the authoritarian moment is
all about this it's about how the
institutions of power have been hijacked
and weaponized by the left
stakeholder capitalism is a very big
aspect of this and this is why you are
seeing the media cover lululemon because
you're a stakeholder in lululemon you
see you don't own
stocks you don't even own lemon pants
you're a dude but
still you have a stake in what lube
lemon does same thing with toyota
you have a stake in what they do
therefore you ought to run
their company hey this is not a recipe
for economic success or
political health for a nation all of
this
has culminated in a wide level of
distrust of major institutions
in the marketplace we'll get to that in
just one second first
let us talk about a simple fact if you
get caught in credit card debt you can
be absolutely screwed i mean credit card
debt is like the worst thing in the
world i know people have gone bankrupt
because of credit card debt
you start letting that rack up those
interest charges rack up month on month
you can be in serious trouble instead
you need to refinance your credit card
balances and lower your interest rate
and save yourself some money you don't
have to be a financial expert to do it
right now
you can get a credit card consolidation
loan from my friends at lightstream with
a rate as low as 5.93
apr with autopay and excellent credit
it's lower than average credit card
interest rates of over 19
apr that means you could be saving
thousands of bucks
in interest and you get a loan from 5
000 to 100 000
with no fees the rate is fixed it's not
gonna go up over the life of the loan
plus you can even get your money in your
bank account as soon as the day you
apply
lightstream believes people with good
credit deserve a better loan experience
that's exactly
what they deliver just for my listeners
you can apply right now get a special
interest rate discount save even more
the only way to get that discount go to
lightstream.com
shapiro that's l-i-g-h-t s-t-r-e-a-m.com
shapiro subject to credit approval rates
range from 5.93
apr to 19.99 apr include a 0.50 autopay
discount
lowest rate requires excellent credit
terms and conditions apply offers are
subject to change without notice visit
lightstream.com
shapiro for more information okay so
a lot of what is going on right now has
been
made much worse by of course the
presence of social media
social media is a combination between
corporations
and the media ecostructure right so on
the one hand they are corporations who
say they are no longer answerable to
their shareholders they are only
answerable to stakeholders
right broader political actors and so
they are very much subject
to media pressure and being cudgelled
into place
beaten into place clubbed into place by
members of the government
also these are the main mechanisms by
which people consume information
so this creates a very bizarre situation
where social media
are both the people who control what you
see and are in turn
controlled by government incentive
programs
and by outside media coverage which can
shape how political actors work
there's this iron triangle that i've
talked about before between social media
media and the democrats the democrats
don't like that social media has been
historically free and open
and has allowed people to post a lot of
material that they don't like and so
they go to the media and they say that
these social media companies are
responsible for every bad thing in the
world
if there's a violent attack it must be
social media if there is a if there's a
story they don't like that's getting out
a hunter biden story for example that's
social media and it needs to be stopped
the media then cover these social media
companies as though they are evil
the more open they are the more evil
they are according to the media it's
amazing
who could have foreseen that the press
being of course a political actor and
not
a a an actor that is in favor of free
speech in the united states the press
has become the chief
they are the chief rooting interest in
favor of shutting down free
dissemination of information it's
unbelievable yeah i think this is
something that the founders probably
could not have foreseen when they said
freedom of the press they assumed that
people who took advantage of the press
would be in favor of a free press rongo
it turns out members of the
quote-unquote press are the people who
are most interested in shutting down
open debate on social media you have the
democrats they launder their message
through media
the media whip up all of this fervor
about how social media is to blame for
all the problems the democrats use that
fervor in order to threaten social media
and social media
in order to avoid regulation then shuts
down free speech right this is the game
this is the game they've been playing
for quite a while the heads of these
companies
will routinely talk about it's amazing
how the messaging has shifted again i
talk about this a lot in my new book the
authoritarian moment it's in about
two weeks now the it is incredible
how the messaging on social media has
shifted in 2012
social media was seen as a godsend by
democrats by republicans it was very
popular
and the reason it was popular in sort of
opinion polls democrats saw it as a way
of reaching
audiences they'd never reached before
also barack obama was brilliant at it
right he was
amazing able to manipulate social media
and get to audiences who had never seen
his message before
you remember that there's this whole
wave of stories about how brilliant
obama's campaign was in 2020 in 2012
using social media and social media was
great
right social media was making the world
a more interconnected better friendlier
place then 2016 happened and trump won
and the democrats had to come up with
some excuse for why it wasn't their
fault
why it wasn't their fault that hillary
clinton the the heir apparent and the
person who'd been
pushed for the presidency since
essentially 1992 by the democratic party
in the media
why she had lost to this real estate
reality tv star
who was wild and bombastic and said
anything that came into his head how
could she possibly have lost and they
came up with a couple of solutions one
was of course russian collusion
it was the evil rooskies and the second
was social media social media had
allowed
messages that never should have been
allowed if only social media had somehow
stopped trump from winning
the country would have been so much
better facebook was bad
facebook had allowed for russian
collusion to happen now as it turned out
statistically speaking the amount of
russian propaganda put out on facebook
was extraordinarily minimal if you
actually look at the stats
not big stats as somebody who is in the
facebook stats like every single day i
can tell you
the amount of russian messaging during
the 2016 election and the impact thereof
via facebook was
minimal on a percentage basis like the
the total number of impressions created
by a by by the russians for like a
period of two years
was equivalent to about the number of
impressions i created for my first
personal facebook page in the course of
maybe a couple of weeks
okay so no it was not a big deal but
that was not the point the point was we
have to get social media now
to shift right social media has to move
from being in favor of
broad open dissemination of information
social media now
has to move into being the content
police and so you saw mark zuckerberg
giving speeches
in 2018 as late as 2017 2018 talking
about how he wanted to
to cut in favor of free speech he wanted
to cut in favor of open dissemination of
information
and then you would see him testify
before congress and saying we're
responsible for the information on our
platform which of course is not true
the minute you say you are responsible
for the information on a social media
platform
now you should be liable for the
information on your platform we here at
daily wire we have legal liability for
the stuff we print our comments section
is governed by section 230 which means
it is a platform we are not liable for
the stuff that appears in the content
section
and i will say that openly if somebody
posted bad comments on daily wire not
our fault not our problem
we try to police some of that stuff to
make sure that the comment section
doesn't turn into a sewer but
that's about it and if somebody does
post something that's really bad in our
comments section we didn't edit it so
you know what
we're not responsible under section 230
or morally speaking
but facebook has started to treat itself
more like the editorial side
then they have treated itself like a
platform right and that's because
democrats decided you must
treat yourself like you're an editorial
site and only then when you treat
yourself like an editorial site will
give you immunity so
they've created this bizarre reverse
situation in which it used to be
legal immunity had been provided four
platforms in order to facilitate open
information
and then the democrats decided that
these open platforms should become
closed edited platforms
in order to retain their immunity which
of course destroys the entire purpose of
the immunity in the first place the
whole purpose of the immunity is to
incentivize open conversation
it is not to shut down open conversation
okay so all of this is culminated in a
lawsuit
that president trump is now filing
against it's it's a class-action lawsuit
that he is filing against facebook
and twitter and youtube and he's doing
this on the basis that they have banned
him but he's suggesting that their
censorship procedures
affect a broad swath of people there's
some problems with the lawsuit
there are also some interesting things
about the lawsuit and i think that
you're you're on the one side you're
hearing people say this is the greatest
lawsuit since sliced bread which it is
not on the other side you're hearing
people say this is absolute crap and
there's no basis for it whatsoever
not quite that either we'll get to that
in just one second first let us talk
about the fact that if you are a
responsible human being
you need life insurance you do policy
genius makes it easy to compare quotes
from over a dozen top insurers all
in one place why comparable you could
save 50 or more on life insurance by
comparing quotes with policy genius
you could save 1300 bucks or more per
year on life insurance by using policy
genius to compare policies
the licensed experts and policy genius
work for you not the insurance companies
so you can trust them to help you
navigate every step of the shopping and
buying process
that kind of service has earned policy
genius thousands of five-star reviews
across trustpilot and google
eligible applicants can get covered in
as little as a week thanks to an
award-winning policy option that swaps
the standard medical exam requirement
for a simple phone call this exclusive
policy was recently rated number one by
forbes higher than options from ladder
ethos and bestow and getting started
super simple first head on over to
policygenius.com shapiro in minutes you
can work out how much life insurance
coverage you need
and compare personalized quotes to find
your best price when you're ready to
apply the policy genius team will handle
the paperwork and the scheduling
for free policy genius never sells your
information to other companies policy
genius does not add on
extra fees head on over to
policygenius.com shapiro get started
right now policy genius when it comes to
insurance it's nice to get it right
god forbid you're hit by a train make
sure your family's taken care of head on
over to policy genius.com
shapiro to get started right now okay so
president trump has now filed a lawsuit
against youtube facebook and twitter all
of whom have banned him which
is frankly an unbelievable thing it is
incredible that the sitting president of
the united states was banned from the
three largest social media services in
the united states
okay so here was so president trump
said in the wall street journal
yesterday one of the greatest threats to
our democracy today
is a powerful group of big tech
corporations that have teamed up with
the government to censor the free speech
of the american people
this is not only wrong it is
unconstitutional to restore free speech
for myself and for every american i am
suing big tech to stop it
social media has become as central to
free speech as town meeting halls
newspapers and television networks were
in prior generations the internet is the
new public square
in recent years however big tech
platforms have become increasingly
brazen and shameless in censoring and
discriminating against ideas information
and people on social media banning users
the platforming organizations
aggressively blocking the free flow of
information on which our democracy
depends
no longer are big tech giants simply
removing specific threats of violence
they're manipulating and controlling the
political debate itself
consider content that was censored in
the past year big tech companies banned
users from their platforms for
publishing evidence that showed the
coronavirus emerged from a chinese lab
which even the corporate media now
admits may be true
in the middle of a pandemic big tech
censored physicians from discussing
potential treatments like
hydroxychloroquine which studies have
now shown does work to relieve symptoms
of cover 19.
in the weeks before a presidential
election the platforms banned the new
york post america's oldest newspaper for
publishing a story critical of joe
biden's family
a story the biden campaign did not even
dispute perhaps most egregious in the
weeks after the election big tech
blocked the social media accounts of the
sitting president
and if they can do it to me they can do
it to you and believe me they are
jennifer horton of michigan school
teacher was banned from facebook for
sharing an article questioning whether
mandatory masks for young children
are healthy later when her brother went
missing she was unable to use facebook
to get the word out
colorado physician kelly victory was
deplatformed by youtube after she made a
video for her church explaining
how to hold services safely kai and
michael of florida and her husband bobby
lost their 21-year-old son in a fatal
collision caused
by a twice deported illegal alien
facebook censored them after they posted
on border security and immigration
enforcement
says this flagrant attack on free speech
is doing terrible damage to our country
that is why in conjunction with the
america first policy institute i filed
class-action lawsuits to force big tech
to stop censoring the american people
our lawsuits argue that big tech
companies are being used to impose
illegal and unconstitutional
government censorship in 1996
rights trump congress sought to promote
the growth of the internet by extending
liability protections to internet
platforms recognizing that they were
exactly that platforms not publishers
unlike publishers companies like
facebook and twitter can't be held
legally liable for the content posted to
their sites without this immunity social
media companies could not exist
democrats in congress are exploiting
this leverage to coerce platform
into censoring their political opponents
in recent years we have all watched
congress haul big tech ceos before the
committees and demand that they censor
quote false stories and disinformation
labels determined by an army of partisan
fact checkers loyal to the democratic
party
further big tech and government agencies
are actively coordinating to remove
content from the platforms
according to the guidance of agencies
like the centers for disease control and
prevention
this coercion and coordination is
unconstitutional okay so
here is where trump is right and here is
where trump is wrong
so he is not wrong when he says that
there are certain activities that can be
undertaken by private companies
that are coincident with government
action and that have been deemed by the
courts in the past
to be government action there's an
article just
back in january by vivek ramaswamy and
jed rubenfeld rubenfeld is a former
professor over at yale
in which they specifically talk about
the
the fact that private companies can in
fact be deemed state actors if proper
government leverage is applied
so for example example it is axiomatic
the supreme court held in norwood versus
harrison that the government quote may
not induce encourage or promote private
persons to accomplish
what it is constitutionally forbidden to
accomplish they say that's what congress
did by enacting section 230 of the 1996
communications decency act which not
only permits tech companies to censor
constitutionally protected speech but
immunizes them from liability
if they do so the justices have long
held that the provision of such immunity
can turn private action into state
action
in railway employees department versus
hanson for example they found state
action and private and union employer
closed shop agreements which forced all
employees to join the union
because congress had passed a statute
immunizing such agreements from
liability under state law
in other words if congress gives some
sort of immunization to liability
and then in order to maintain the
immunity congress cudgels
companies to do a thing that can be
deemed state action in skinner versus
railway labor executives association the
court again found state action in
private party conduct
drug tests for company employees because
federal regulations immunize railroads
from liability if they conducted those
tests
in both cases with section 230 the
federal government didn't mandate
anything
it merely preempted state law protecting
certain private parties from lawsuits
if they engaged in conduct congress was
promoting
okay so this is the part where trump is
not wrong for example
so if these social media companies were
granted
i mean it's immunity from liability by
section 230 because section 230 was
designed
to basically promote open speech on the
internet and
yes to allow social media companies to
curate content
now the idea behind section 230 is that
you shouldn't be punished as a publisher
if for example you started curating your
comment section to get rid of things
like pornography
if you curated your comment section to
get rid of obscenity or violence or
other
maybe first amendment protected
activities but you just want to clean
the comments section
okay how and section 230 does in fact
protect
for example even a sort of partisan
cleansing
of platforms right if you if you go
through and you get rid of all the
anti-trump commentary in the comments
section of a particular website this
does not relieve section 230
liability or section 230 immunity
right you can you can still do that but
this changes
once the government starts applying
pressure once the government starts
applying pressure and saying we are
going to remove
your immunity we're gonna that immunity
is going to go away
unless you censor the kinds of content
we want you to censor
now that looks a lot more like state
action and so the the trump
argument in the lawsuit is a little too
broad for my liking he says that
communications
decency act section 230 is fully
unconstitutional
in that particular lawsuit he says that
that that basically
created a section of immunity from
liability
that is not constitutional in the first
place which is questionable
at best i don't think that that's right
immunity there's no immunity
to that like liability is not written
into the constitution
okay there's nothing in the constitution
that says you are definitely liable
if you don't print x or y of course
because free speech still applies to
private corporations however once the
government starts
forcing corporations with threat of
legislation into censoring what they
want them to censor
now that looks like compelled state
action right now that looks like these
companies have basically become
mercantilist free speech outlets for the
democratic party
and that's why it is so troubling when
you see people like dianne feinstein
threatening facebook if you don't stop
this we will
well once you say that then what is
facebook exactly going to do in order to
maintain their own business
they're going to have to do what dianne
feinstein wants them to do
and this means that you have to start
treating these people like state actors
or maybe you do right that that legal
theory is not
nearly as wild as the media are making
it out to be they say the media like
well it's a private company they can do
exactly what they want which is weird
because the media have yet to
the same media that will tell you that
lululemon cannot do what it wants
because there are three woke employees
who are pissed off at a guy who left the
company a year ago
those same people will tell you facebook
can do exactly what it wants
in censoring content as long as that
content that they are censoring is the
right content to censor
okay well there is actually a fairly
large difference between even lululemon
doing what it wants
and facebook doing what the government
tells it to do in order to maintain its
immunity from liability
and that is the case that trump is
making clarence thomas has sort of
hinted at this in the past so it's not
quite as wild a lawsuit as people are
suggesting now do i think that the
lawsuit is actually going to go all the
way i doubt it trump says that he's
going to sit for a deposition i can't
imagine he will
because if he has to sit for a
deposition no lawyer in the world is
going to allow donald trump to sit for a
deposition
he is the worst legal client on planet
earth there's a reason he's gone through
every lawyer in america
to the point where he ended up like
sydney powell right he went through
every lawyer because
the first rule of being a lawyer is tell
your client to shut up and donald trump
he didn't do that so he ain't gonna be
sitting for a deposition he says he will
but he probably won't but
when you hear people on the left
suddenly dismissing that oh well
companies can do what they want
come i swear the same people who say
facebook can do what it wants in
censoring content demand that facebook
sense our content that is not
a coincidence kara swisher is like how
dare you suggest that facebook isn't a
private company
also facebook should definitely censor
the content i want them to censor or
they should be regulated
i'm sensing a bit of a conflict there
already meanwhile in just a second
joe biden continues to fuss around i'm
amazed
honestly amazed that we are about to
surrender in afghanistan to the taliban
and nobody seems to care that is amazing
to me
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about the fact you
don't need to go to the auto parts store
who needs to go to the auto parts store
nobody
rock auto dot com okay rock comes a lot
easier than going to the auto parts
store you wait in line for like an hour
you get to the front
finally the guy behind the the counter
he finally asks you a bunch of questions
you type something into the computer
it's like oh yeah we don't have that
part in stock we're gonna order it come
back in three weeks like my car doesn't
even work right now what are you talking
about like oh yeah and also we're gonna
upcharge you by 25
or you can go to rockladder.com you get
the product delivered directly to your
house and then you can just do it
yourself right this is what rockauto.com
does
they always offer the lowest prices
possible rather than changing prices
based on what the market will bear
like airlines do why would you spend up
to twice as much for the same parts
their family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years go to rockauto.com to shop for
auto and body parts from hundreds of
manufacturers the catalog's unique
and remarkably easy to navigate quickly
see all the parts available for your
vehicle and choose
the brand's specifications and prices
you prefer
go to rockgarden.com right now see all
the parts available for that car or
truck right shapiro in there how did you
hear about us box so they know that we
sent you again that is rockauto.com
go check them out right now and again
remind them that you heard about them
here on the ben shapiro show also quick
announcement
would you like to work here well now is
your chance the daily wire is hiring a
web
marketing specialist to do well a bunch
of technical stuff that i don't
understand and that i'll pay you to do
but seriously if you know how to
optimize a website experience if you've
done a b testing before if you're a data
loving nerd
that i am then this is the job for you
so head over to dailywire.com
careers apply right now as you know we
are the fastest growing conservative
media company in the country we are not
slowing down anytime soon
it seems like there's a new employee
around here every single day like it
takes me as everybody here knows it
takes me like five times meeting you
before i even know your name
and it's getting worse because we have
so many employees maybe the next
employee whose name i won't know
would be you again that is dailywear.com
careers go apply
today also from pronouns to
microaggressions language has been
turned into a tool
used by the political left to silence
dissenters and ostracize them from
friends and family
that's why michael knowles took it upon
himself to write a book about it the
book is called speechless controlling
words controlling minds
if you have not picked up a copy now
would be a good time to do so the book
will take you through the origins of
political correctness white is essential
we stand up and fight it's insidious
spread into every public institution
in america because if we don't the
consequences are waiting for us and our
kids
in the very very near future and here is
the thing
the book is good and also it has sold a
bajillion copies and is just being
boycotted by the new york times it just
is demonstrative of how the left shuts
down anything that it doesn't like the
book was the number one non-fiction
bestseller in the country going into the
july 4th holiday according to publishers
weekly it didn't even hit the new york
times best seller list
at all last week the new york times
number one bestseller sold a grand total
of 6 900 copies
speechless sold 6 600 copies it wasn't
on the top 15.
so if you don't know the history and
relevance of political correctness
already you're about to find out
just go pick up a copy of speechless
controlling words controlling minds it's
available everywhere right now
if you don't feel like making a trip
it's available on amazon in hardcover
and kindle edition you are listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
meanwhile joe biden is just losing
afghanistan he's just decided to
surrender in afghanistan now what's
unbelievable about this truly
is that afghanistan was in a state of
stasis
it wasn't a war that was won in any
realistic sense the taliban was still
around
obviously but the country had not been
ceded to the taliban the taliban
did not have control of the entire
territory it could not really provide
safe havens for wide varieties of
terrorist groups
it was still being fought to a
standstill at the very
least by the afghan government and we
are pulling out at a time when we are
spending
approximately 50 billion dollars a year
in afghanistan that's how much money
that we've been spending in afghanistan
as of like 2019 that represents
approximately
1.3 percent of a four trillion dollar
budget and now that we're talking about
spending you know
one bajillion dollars well it represents
a tiny tiny drop in the bucket the
number of american soldiers were being
killed in combat every year was in the
single digits this was not an endless
war in other words
it's not i'm sorry it doesn't count as a
war when when a single digit number of
your soldiers are being killed in it
every single year and there are more
cops who are being killed on the streets
of chicago every year than we're being
soldiers being killed in afghanistan
every year so that does not count as as
an endless war
in any realistic sense the only reason
that joe biden is withdrawing is because
he wants
to to suggest that he did it and the
left will never blame him
for the fallout and there will be
fallout i mean tens of thousands of
people will undoubtedly be made into
refugees you'll see thousands
of people murdered you'll see anyone who
worked with the american government
killed outright you'll see women forced
back into effectively channel slavery
which is what they were living like in
afghanistan before the united states got
there
and this notion that that long-term
occupation of countries has
no positive effect is just silly
and the united states still has bases in
south korea and guess what
after the korean war we should note that
after the korean war it was not as
though the us's presence
was widely appreciated in south korea it
was not as though
south korea immediately transformed into
a successful market democracy
it took a long time there was a
a full military dictatorship in south
korea
for a fairly significant period of time
and an extraordinary amount of
corruption in south korea
before the the so-called sixth republic
was founded
there's a reason it was called the sixth
republic because it took a lot of go
around
in order to get to anything remotely
resembling an actual republic
in south korea there's still high levels
of corruption in south korea it is also
a thriving market economy
and so the notion that when america
pulls out things get better just doesn't
it's not true
and guess what long-term occupations
that don't have tremendously high costs
to the united states
actually are not a horrible thing they
are not you know what's the worst thing
ceding control of a country to the
taliban we used to actually
understand this sort of stuff in the
united states and
i know that there's this weird idea in
the aftermath of world war ii the united
states basically just everyone came home
and that's not true a huge percentage of
soldiers did come home because the
active military combat was over
but there was still a bunch of soldiers
who were sitting around in germany
there's a bunch of soldiers sitting
around
there are still a bunch of soldiers
sitting it is now 2021
world war ii ended in 1945. okay it has
been
nearly 80 years since the end of world
war ii we still have bases in germany
and japan
the korean war ended in the early 50s we
still have bases in south korea so the
bizarre notion that we win anything by
pulling out of afghanistan is weird it
is a weird thing
and it's not only weird it is stupid
because again it will be treated by all
of america's worst enemies
as a big win for the taliban and so they
drove the united states out
what they really did is they just waited
for the united states to get bored and
then we unilaterally pulled out when
there was really no
effective reason to joe biden like an
idiot says the united states has
achieved its objectives which of course
is not true
yesterday speaking after the withdrawal
of nearly all u.s combat forces
and as the taliban surge across the
country biden spoke directly to critics
of his order to bring an end to american
participation in a conflict born
from the terrorist attacks of september
11th he said let me ask those who want
us to stay
how many more how many thousands more
american daughters and sons are you
willing to risk how long would you have
them stay
um what do you mean thousands more are
you willing to risk
since when are thousands of americans
dying in afghanistan
like really you can say thousands of
americans died in afghanistan at the
beginning of the war when we were
responding to you know the murder of 3
000 americans in new york and washington
dc
but when we were losing like
single-digit soldiers per year
in afghanistan in an active combat
situation um
that is like he has to exaggerate for a
fact it's the only way that he can
justify what he is doing
because a lot of people have been
pointing out quite correctly that joe
biden's policy here is
indistinguishable on every available
level i mean truly indistinguishable
from pulling out from saigon in 1975 and
handing the entire country
over to the viet cong which resulted in
hundreds of thousands of people
fleeing many of them literally getting
in boats to get out of vietnam
and the fall of cambodia and the murder
of two million people by pol pot in
cambodia
right he he's gonna have there this sort
of withdrawal leaves blood on american
hands in the same way there was blood on
american hands we made promises to the
kurds in 1991
and then just let saddam hussein go in
and slaughter them there is blood on
american hands when you make promises to
people and those people rely on those
promises
and then to prevent not even a high cost
scenario
to prevent a very very low cost scenario
relatively speaking with regard to
american foreign policy you withdraw
all troops joe biden's position here
makes no sense
at all well yesterday joe biden
he got slightly tongue-tied announcing
the afghanistan withdrawal because again
joe biden is in a running
gun battle with the teleprompter here
was president biden getting
a little confused about the afghanistan
withdrawal yesterday
we're going to continue to work for the
release of detained americans including
uh mark uh excuse me
fred ferrigs i i want to pronounce the
name
correctly i miss i misspoke so that he
can return to his family safely
um yeah that that is again him versus
this
daughtering old fool is now going to
lead to the fall of afghanistan again
and there will be long term downstream
effects
there will be i mean the fact is that
the united states troop presence in
germany prevented
not only the russians from taking over
western europe
but also ended up forestalling the
possibility of germany turning back into
something horrific
the same thing in japan the same thing
in south korea i point this out because
people seem to have forgotten basic
american history
and there seems to be this bizarre
left-wing noam chomsky opinion that
anywhere american boots go things get
worse
that is not true generally where
american boots withdraw
things get massively worse i mean
the united states you know got involved
in in the haitian situation in the 1990s
since america has not been so involved
in haiti how have things gone over there
has
things been like great over in haiti
last time i checked
hey joe biden he's basically admitting
at this point that the mission is
failing
it's incredible he says don't worry the
mission hasn't failed yet okay that's
always a great indicator it's always
very encouraging when the president of
the united states says
well we're withdrawing from afghanistan
come on man and we haven't failed he
checks his watch looks yet
very very encouraging stuff here from
the president of the united states
how serious was the corruption among the
afghanistan government to this mission
failing there
well first of all the mission hasn't
failed yet
there is uh in afghanistan
and all parties there's been corruption
the question is can there be an
agreement on unity of purpose
okay it's amazing we haven't lost yet
great great you know we hadn't lost yet
when they started pushing american
helicopters off the top of the us
embassy in saigon
we hadn't lost yet oh except we did
except we did
okay and then biden was asked well
aren't you going to be responsible for
what happens next considering the fact
that
our cost of remaining in afghanistan was
very low by historic american standards
and considering the fact that when we
abandoned afghanistan thousands of
people will undoubtedly be murdered
don't you bear some responsibility no
man i've never born responsibility
for damn thing um get me on amtrak
here's the
president of the united states will the
united states
be responsible for the loss of afghan
civilian lives that could happen
after no military exit no no no
it's up to the people of afghanistan to
decide on what government they want
not us to impose the government on them
no country has ever been able to do that
keep in mind as a student of history as
i'm sure you are
never has afghanistan been a united
country
not in all of its history
okay we can't impose a government on
afghanistan they have to choose the
government they want
is he suggesting that that when the
taliban completely overruns the place
that this is the government that the
afghan people want
they are desperate to have the taliban
back in power
this is this is the same sort of
argument again that the left used to use
during the vietnam war that the
vietnamese clearly want communism they
clearly do just as the south koreans
presumably wanted communism except they
didn't
yes clearly here's the thing the united
states has actually allowed for
elections to take place in afghanistan
and that is much more a reflection of
quote-unquote what the people want then
you know
an armed terrorist group running over
the country
and then stuffing women in burkas and
taking them out of school
like that it is incredible how the
president of the united states is
currently doing the propaganda work of
the taliban
he is when he says that that they get to
choose the
the government that they want and you
know if we walk away and the taliban
take over probably that's the government
that they want
that is some ugly ugly stuff the reality
is the only thing on the ground allowing
the afghans to make any choice at all
is that is that baseline presence of
american troops
and then so biden predictably enough was
asked if you trust the taliban no i
don't trust the tale
so then why are you so then why are you
suggesting that the afghan government
which is weak and has historically been
weak because
again there isn't he's correct that
there's been no history of democracy in
afghanistan before the united states got
there there's been no history of
security
in afghanistan before the united states
got there which is why it takes a long
time
okay why democracy can't be simply
grafted on to afghanistan's roots but
that doesn't mean that safety and
security
and the value of human rights can't be
grafted on to those roots over time
over time being the key word and he's
just removed the timetable
here is the president of the united
states saying well no no i don't trust
the taliban i'm just going to hand over
the entire country to them
you trust the television are you is that
a serious question it's
absolutely a serious question you trust
the taliban no i do not
want the country to the taliban no i do
not trust the taliban will you amplify
your answer please why you don't it's a
silly question do i trust the taliban no
but i trust the capacity of the afghan
military
who is better trained better equipped
and more re
more competent in terms of conducting
war
um no he doesn't no he doesn't i mean
he really doesn't i mean and if he does
he's an idiot if he thinks that the
afghan government is going to suddenly
hold up in the face of the taliban right
now
then there would be no controversy and
this is
again this is disconnected from reality
all he wants is a cheap political win
it's not really even going to be a win
because let me just tell you five
minutes after we leave and the headlines
come out about how the taliban are
rounding up women who are going to
school and slaughtering them in the
streets
those headlines ain't going to look good
for joe biden
in fact jen jensocki is basically
acknowledging as much right she says
we're not going to have a mission
accomplished this is a war that hasn't
been won
so what are you accomplishing by
withdrawing then exactly explain
in terms of plans uh for the end uh uh
for our men and women uh coming back
i don't have anything to preview but we
don't we're not going to have a mission
accomplished moment
in this regard it's a 20-year
war that has not been won militarily
um so she's admitting that they they
haven't won anything
so there's no gain here it is all just
politics which is
pretty pretty horrifying but you know
what
it's okay everything's fine the biden
administration
is um the binding administration is
friendly with the media so it really
doesn't matter yesterday jen saki she
did the outreach to the media that they
so deeply crave she gave them the
attention they so deeply want
she she had she led a singing of happy
birthday for reuters is
steve holland now listen chicken is
friendly in the press room and she wants
to be
that's nice okay what is so what is not
as nice as the fact that the media then
reciprocate by slobbering all over the
biden administration
here here was jen saki dealing with um
frankly her propaganda wing
who's with me someone here has a good
voice happy birthday
to you happy birthday
dear
[Music]
oh yeah there is the free press
excellent voice
oh brian cameron oh oh isn't it nice and
uh well
i guess they don't have to cover the
news anymore i mean after all so
refreshing
how refreshing is jen's hockey alrighty
we'll be back here later today with an
additional hour of content first
you can't forget to end your week by
checking out the andrew clavin show
drew's shows every friday he's got an
exciting evening planned for you
so head on over to dailywire.com 7 p.m
eastern 6 pm central tune in
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavel wydowsky
associate producer bradford carrington
host producer justin barbour
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by
mike coromina hair and makeup is by
fabiola christina production assistant
jessica kranz
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started so come on over to the
andrew clavin show and laugh your way
through the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin
[Music]